then how could you vote Republican David
reportedly asked musk this is a story
that just came out because you know
there's this biography that just it just
came out or it's coming out next week it
just came out a week ago of Elon Musk uh
and in the biography there is a story
about when Elon Musk met Larry David
Larry David in some ways is probably my
biggest comic icon in that he created uh
Seinfeld with Jerry Seinfeld the
character of George is based on him I
don't know that any show affected me
more than Seinfeld in terms of like
comedy and I lived in New York City like
basically a block away from where Jerry
lived in real life which was like two
blocks away from where he lived on the
show and that whole thing was my life in
many ways for 15 or 20 years he then
obviously went on to create Curb Your
Enthusiasm but he is like a crazy crazy
leftist which he kind of acknowledges by
the way on the show which is at least I
will give him credit for that but but I
love this guy in terms of the art right
so I guess what I'm talking about today
is sort of separating the art from the
artist and it can be very very hard to
do but anyway a story about Larry David
meeting Elon Musk was out in this
autobiography in the New York Post
covered it and I thought it was kind of
interesting comedian Larry David
reportedly wanted Elon Musk to curb his
enthusiasm for the Republican party in a
scene that could have easily come from
David's HBO hit show The irascible
Seinfeld co-creator confronted the Tesla
boss at a super agent at super agent Ari
Emmanuel's star-studded wedding in San
Tropez France last year David and
Emmanuel client who officiated the
nuptials between the talent agent and
fashion designer Sarah stoutinger was
seated at a table that included musk
according to author Walter Isaacson in
his new biography titled Elon Musk
Isaacson wrote that David seemed to be
fuming according to Isaacson David ass
musk do you just want to murder kids in
school David appeared to be referencing
the mass shooter in Uvalde Texas which
claimed the lives of 19 children and two
teachers the killings took place just
four days before the May 28th wedding no
no musk who was said to be baffled and
annoyed replied I'm anti-kid murder the
Mogul reportedly told David then how
could you vote Republican David
reportedly asked musk Isaacson wrote
that David confirmed to him the details
of the reported encounter so again do
you see what I'm trying to do here I
don't want to go after Larry David I
would love to meet Larry David and have
a stop and chat as he would say okay but
these people that are somehow in charge
of our culture get all of the important
things wrong and then it leads to bad
politics so that Larry David would be at
a wedding in San Tropez France one of
the most beautiful places in the world
surrounded by all rich and beautiful
people sitting at a table with Elon Musk
a billionaire yelling at him because of
his support for Republicans which Elon
Musk is and even a republican he's we've
discussed it on the show many times he's
basically just a disaffected liberal and
his entire life he only voted for
Democrats until the last but Larry David
felt the righteous indignation to
basically say you want to kill kids
while at Ari Emmanuel's wedding